so thank you everyone for showing up for
the last talk of the day you know it's
been a long day so I'll be talking about
some techniques for handling unbalanced
datasets so in your classification tasks
so a number of classification problems
need to deal with class imbalance
amongst amongst the various classes and
we say we have a class imbalance problem
when one class has a significantly
higher or lower representation in our
training dataset distribution and often
in these problems or at least the kind
of problems that I'll be focusing on the
performance on the minority class is
what we really care about and if you
take your favorite classifier and feed
it this unbalanced data said this you
might not get the performance that that
you are looking for so we will see some
ways of mitigating that that problem so
some examples the the quintessential
example that comes to mind is fraud
detection so you have a lot of
transactions coming in say you're a
finance company like PayPal a small
number of these transactions would be
fraudulent but most of them would be
genuine and if you want to build a
classifier that identifies fraudulent
transactions you would have a day time
balance problem the next example which
is close to the domain that I work in at
Walmart is product categorization so say
you're a retailer and you sell a lot of
products say you sell iPhones and you
sell iPhone accessories typically if
you're optimizing for revenue you would
want users coming to your website to be
able to find the iPhones and add the
cost of some iPhone accessory buyers
seeing some iPhone also in the result
another example would be disease
diagnosis it's a fair assumption that
for any given disease most people are
healthy and the fraction of people who
are the disease is typically small and
there are a lot of examples
like this if you browse the UCI a
machine-learning data set repository
you'll see a lot of examples of
unbalanced data set so this talk is
basically going to be a survey of some
techniques which are going to be
presented by our case study on a
synthetic data set and the main main
kinds of techniques that we will talk
about are either you modify the loss
function so machine learning problems
essentially boil down to minimizing some
loss function on your data set but and
we'll see how to modify the loss
function and get better better
performance the other thing you can do
is modify the dataset itself which would
form the bulk of the talk this includes
resampling techniques and finally we'll
finish with a couple of ensemble methods
so just to fix some notation will denote
the majority class by L will will
basically be talking with reference to a
two class classification problem so
there are two classes l and s where L is
the majority class and s is the minority
class and abusing notation will
basically use it both for the set of
examples in the majority class and also
the class label itself now I know
Florine gave a talk earlier of having a
single metric but just for the purposes
of this discussion the objectives that
we want on the data set is to have a
high recall on the minority class and
high precision on the majority class and
you can combine these two metrics into a
single metric by taking either the
geometric mean or harmonic mean and
there are a lot of other techniques that
are proposed in literature that can
capture this intent of quantifying
better performance on the minority class
now why does this objective make sense
so typically again with reference to the
examples that were on the slide earlier
if you're detecting fraud then you would
like to have catch all the pradhan
transactions catch all of them if
possible at the risk of potentially
flagging some genuine transactions on
fraudulent because the next step of the
process is typically an analyst
is going to review those transactions
and if a few genuine transactions slip
through that that's something that we
can deal with but Prada land
transactions getting missed have a much
higher cost
so just to recap precision and recall
here so precision is the fraction of
things that will classify as the
majority class that we get correct and
recall on the minority class this means
that the fraction of items that were
that are actually in the minority class
get flagged as minority class so most of
this talk is I mean being a pied-a-terre
talk is done in Python the talk itself
and all the visualizations and all the
machine learning machine learning models
that are built out in Python so you're
basically using a scikit-learn for
building models reusing matplotlib or
doing visualization and the main focus
of the talk which is these balancing
techniques these come from this library
called imbalanced learn so that's the I
am we learn that you are seeing so let's
let's first generate a synthetic dataset
so scikit-learn has this method called
make classification which you can use to
generate all kinds of data set it was
it's it's based upon on this challenge
from a neural information processing
conference from I think 2003 you can
specify a lot of parameters here you can
specify how your classes are separated
that's the one point to capture here the
weights we are using is 0.1 and 0.9 this
this means that the number of items in
the majority class are nine times that
in the minority class now we can have
significantly more skewed distribution
than this so I personally dealt with
datasets where the ratio of majority to
mine on your class was anywhere from 100
to 10,000 and we can handle a lot of
those problems using these methods as
well but in the interest of being able
to visualize a lot of these datasets
let's go with
somewhat more manageable class
distribution will generate 10,000
samples and will basically generate two
clusters and there are some other
parameters that you can tweak to get the
kind of data set that you want the next
thing we do is split the data set into
70% training and 30% training sorry 30%
testing we'll train our models on the
70% and see the performance on the
holdout test set so how does this data
look like so if you see the orange dots
represent the majority class and the
blue dots represent the minority class
and the way it stands right now it it's
clear that the majority class is
overwhelming the data set but the data
still forms two fairly distinct clusters
and if we care about performance on the
minority class say we are using a linear
classifier we kind of have an idea of
where you would like a decision boundary
to be to be able to capture most of the
minority class examples so let's let's
see what we get right out of the box so
let's use logistic regression from
scikit-learn
we'll do five fold cross validation to
search for the best parameters here are
the parameters that I am optimizing for
include the penalty whether it's Elvin
penalty or l2 and the regularization
parameter over a few set of values so if
we do this we get the best parameters
and we get the logistic regression
decision boundary and this is the
boundary that we get you see that most
of the examples are on one side of the
boundary regardless of what class
they're in so this this doesn't really
do justice to the kind of objectives
that we have if you look at the
performance on the test set so I'll be
having these kind of visualizations and
metrics for most of the techniques the
main thing to focus on are the diagonal
entries the first two diagonal entries
so the precision on the majority class
is not great it's 90% and the recoil on
the minority
is really poor just 12% so let's see
what using some of these techniques buys
us so the first is asymmetric loss
functions so as I said machine learning
problems boil down to defining some kind
of a loss function that you run an
optimization algorithm on to try and
minimize in the case of logistic
regression you have this negative
conditional log likelihood that you are
trying to minimize and the cost the
logistic sigmoid function is symmetric
the cost of making of this
classification one way or the other
it basically cost the same but we can
modify that and we can attach a weight
to each class and if we do that we can
somehow encode the information that we
want to we care more about the
performance on the minority class in
this instance so scikit-learn
provides a way to do this using the
class weight parameter so here we use
the balanced a balanced value for this
parameter there are custom weights that
you can choose the balance heuristic
basically tries to attach wheels that
are inversely proportional to the size
of your to the size of the class so it
essentially is trying to convey the
information that we can more about the
minority class because because of the
inverse proportionality and if we do
that we already see that we get a much
better much better decision boundary so
if we look at the performance on the
test class test set that's reflected
here now we get a precision on the
majority class which is 98% which is
better than what we got doing nothing at
all and the recall on the minority class
has significantly improved to 89% so
that that's that's all I wanted to talk
about regarding modifying the loss
function the next set of techniques
would be about resampling the data set
and the
first few of those would be about
undersampling the majority class so the
simplest thing that you can do is
randomly under sample so you treat each
point in the majority class like any
other and just randomly choose to ignore
some of the points so here we see that
there are a lot of blue points there are
a lot of orange points and we randomly
choose to ignore some of them so this
this can cause a problem because we can
sometimes lose informative examples so
especially if if you have a lot of
outliers so in this case we have this
outlier algorithm didn't really
understand politican other--and impede
you might lose that so that is the main
problem but if your dataset is such that
every example in the majority class is
surrounded by other examples of the
majority class then it might not be such
a bad thing to do so now this is where
the imbalance learn library comes into
play this to the first line in most of
these slides is going to be the method
that we are using so this is just the
random and the sampler and then there's
this ratio parameter which basically
says what is the ratio we want off
minority class to majority class so at
the bottom if you look at the
distribution before under sampling we
had six 6300 examples in the majority
class and 700 odd in the minority class
after and the sampling the majority
class examples goes down to about 1300
so now when we look at visualization of
the training set we can clearly identify
how the minority class looks like and we
can definitely be able to draw a much
better decision boundary which is what
logistic regression is able to do on
this three sample data set and if we
look at the performance on the test set
we get 97 percent precision which is
about the same as with weighted classes
and 82 percent recall on the minority
class so these are these are two I mean
the first things that you could try
which are fairly simple and fairly easy
to understand and a lot of times these
the performance with these two
techniques is quite hard to beat now
we'll see some more sophisticated ways
of doing under sampling or over sampling
which might not necessarily give a
better performance on this data set but
might perform better on some other data
set so the first of those is a family of
techniques called near-miss so most of
these techniques are based on the
nearest neighborhood kind of argument so
you try to find examples to either
select or deselect based on how close
they are to certain other examples the
first technique is near miss one so here
you retain points from the majority
class whose mean distance to K nearest
points in the minority class is the
lowest so you take all examples in the
majority class rank order them based on
the distances mean distances to their K
nearest neighbors and then depending on
what kind of under sampling ratio you
want to achieve you choose to ignore the
the top view and with near miss one it
tends to basically lose or tends to
retain points which are close to the
boundary between the two classes so if
you have data set like this it might not
really do well and as we will soon see
it doesn't so again the first line is
the algorithm for under sampling the
ratio again we want to use point five
the size neighborhood here is three so
some of these values of these parameters
are tunable but the choices that I'm
making now are what were made in the
original papers so most of these
techniques come from fairly highly cited
papers on this on this topic and that's
the kind of choices that they made or
what worked from them is a good starting
point so let's see what kind of data set
that we get after under sampling so as
we see the points that are retained most
of them are certain to be overlapping
with on the minority class examples and
as a result the decision boundary
is not that great it essentially has the
same kind of distribution on either side
on on them and the minority to sorry on
the test set you get a precision of 92
percent on the majority class and a
recall of only 32 percent on the
minority class which is much worse than
the two simple methods that we saw
earlier a slightly better way of doing
this is near-miss 2 which basically does
the same kind of thing except instead of
looking at the nearest point it looks at
the K farthest points in the in the
minority class and again depending on
what ratio you want to achieve it
ignores the first few examples so near
means 2 tends to retain points which are
sort of at the center of the clusters
which is what you see here so this
outlier and these points which are
overlapping with a minority class they
are gone and we have this much cleaner
cluster that you get so this can work
well in some cases so let's see how it
does on the data set that we have again
we use a neighborhood of 3 and the same
ratio around the sampling so if you look
at the under sample data set you see
most of the points which are close to
the center get preserved so essentially
what it's trying to do is preserve
points which are close to all the points
in the minority class if you look at the
performance on the test set the
precision gets is improve over near-miss
1 it's still not as good as either under
sampling random under sampling or
weighted classes and the recall on the
minority class is almost twice as much
as near miss one but still nowhere near
what we get by doing weighting or random
and the sampling finally a third variant
is near miss 3 in which you basically
pick K nearest neighbors of every point
in the minority class the in this case
you might I mean actually you wouldn't
be able to choose
sampling issue because that's codified
in this in this parameter K and a lot of
times there is an overlap between the
nearest neighbors of two different
points and so you you might get more
under sampling than you desire the
library that we use here implements a
slight variant of the near-miss
algorithm then what is described in the
paper but at the ratio that we have
chosen so at the size neighborhood that
we've chosen it doesn't really matter if
we look at the distribution after under
sampling it's close to you know it's
close to 1 instead of 0.5 and if you
visualize the data said we see a lot of
positive example a lot of majority class
examples surrounding minority class
examples again doesn't give a very
cleaner representation of the decision
boundary and again reflected on the test
set only ninety one percent precision on
the majority class and the recall on the
minority class is pretty bad so the
original people looked at this technique
on some other problems and they're
they're finding was near miss to tends
to perform slightly better than and
Amanda sampling and performs much better
than near miss one and near miss three
another nearest neighborhood based
technique is condensed nearest neighbor
so Candice nearest neighbors basically
tries to ignore points from the majority
class which are close to other points in
the majority class so what it does is
you you start with your training set and
you start growing the under sampled data
set so let's call that u and initially
you just choose a random point from the
training set and call it u after that
you basically scan the remaining points
in the training set and see if they are
correctly classified by their nearest
neighbors in the under sample set so
initially when you have just one point
you see you look at the first point in
the remaining
that see whether it has the same class
whether it has the same class as the
point in you if it does then you move
then you deselect that and if it doesn't
then you add it to add it to you and you
keep repeating this process until you is
maximal and a variant of this technique
which is what is implement in the
library is to just under sample the
majority class using this technique and
not the entire training set so if you
look at this cartoon we see that these
points that are in the center their
closest neighbors have the same class as
them and so these get removed after and
the sampling one problem with condense
nearest neighbor or actually two
problems one of them is because we are
growing this with some random point
selected from the training set the the
entire selection procedure becomes
random and so it tends to be high
variance algorithm the other problem is
we are going through repeated scans of
the data set and that if for large data
sets that can be a problem so in the
algorithms that I present here the
kindest nearest neighbor takes the
longest to get the under sampled data
set so there are no real parameters to
tune here we just run condense nearest
neighbors the ratio or after under
sampling that we get is close to one
slightly more examples in the majority
class and again it tends to preserve at
least for this data set it preserves
points in the majority class which are
close to the decision boundary just
because anything which is far off most
of the points that were here their
nearest neighbor in the majority class
these are the points that get retained
and their nearest neighbors happened to
be of the same class performance on the
test set is not very encouraging for
this problem
so 93% precision on the majority class
and only 39% recalled
the minority class a variant of condense
nearest neighbors is edited nearest
neighbors so here the idea is to remove
examples whose class label differs from
a majority of its K nearest neighbor
it's sort of does a complimentary job to
what K nearest neighbors does and a
variant of this is to keep doing that so
you run one pass of dehydrated nearest
neighbors and then keep doing that until
you can no longer edit out any points
from the dataset so here the first step
does shows one pass of edited nearest
neighbors so all these points that so
this point got removed because it has
one neighbor which has a different class
and yeah that's basically the key so
here points get removed here because two
of their neighbors have different
classes and the final step shows what we
get after performing repeated edited
nearest neighbors after which we can no
longer edit out anything
so here everybody has neighbors which
are of the same class so I didn't
nearest neighbors can perform a well
especially in combination with some
other techniques that will talk about
subsequently so the first step of editor
nearest neighbors we implement with a
neighborhood of five and after the
sampling we don't really reduce the the
majority class significantly we only
lose about 1200 examples and look at the
visualization it actually looks to be
doing or it seems to be heading on the
right track we can clearly see examples
from the minority class there are a few
examples from the majority class which
are on the wrong side of the decision
boundary which kind of methods of the
performance but this looks like a good
first step in terms of performance in
the test that it's not as good as some
of the other methods we only get a
recall of 59% of the minority class but
if we do repeat an edited near
neighbors we see some improvement in
performance so now after doing repeated
edited nearest neighbors we lose another
500 examples from the majority class and
if you look at the resample data set now
the the cluster of minority class
samples is much cleaner there are still
some examples from the majority class
here but this this is still a
significant improvement over just a
little nearest neighbors and if you look
at the performance in their test set
that's probably the best performance
we've gotten except for the random and
the sampling and weighted losses so we
get to up to 80% recall on the minority
class and we'll come back to these
methods in a few minutes the next method
which has had a lot of success in some
applications is to make link removal so
atomic link is basically a pair of
examples in your training set which are
each other's nearest neighbors but which
have different slash labels so here
these points that you see are atomic
links so the under sampling strategy is
to basically remove examples which are
from atomic link and a variant is to
just remove majority class examples
which are members of atomic links so the
idea behind this is if if you are part
of atomic link then either you are on
the boundary between two classes so
points which are close to the boundary
tend to have a neighbor which is of the
opposite last or you are you are a noisy
example so you are a minority class
example surrounded by members of the
majority class or vice versa so we can
get rid of these noisy examples and
borderlining samples and get a much
cleaner description of the decision
boundary in our case it doesn't seem to
have that we can effect simply because
it doesn't achieve a lot of
undersampling
that's partly because there are not a
lot of comic links in this data set and
again now we'll revisit this in
combination with some other techniques
so the under sample data set only loses
about 250 or so points yeah so in terms
of the visualization there is not much
difference from the raw data set and
again that's reflected in the
performance on the test set we only get
21% recall on the minority class the
other side of the spectrum is over
sampling so you can you you want to
basically reduce the importance of the
minority class relative of the majority
class relative to the minority class you
can achieve this by doing under sampling
of the majority class or alternatively
canned over sample examples from the
minority class and the problem with this
is that it may lead to over crypting you
are essentially counting the same
examples so many times depending on what
kind of over sampling they show you want
so if we do random over sampling here
again with the ratio of 0.5 now you see
that the number of examples in the
majority class don't change and the
number of examples in the minority class
is about 3,000 in terms of visualization
you are not going to see anything
different because the new points the new
blue points are on top of other blue
points in terms of performance it can
perform fairly well on some datasets so
here we get 97% precision on majority
class and 76% recon on minority class
which is better than a lot of methods
but still worse than both random and the
sampling and weighted classes a more
sophisticated way of doing over sampling
is what is called smooth so this have
this is a paper by nearly Chou law and
it had a lot of success in a lot of
applications the the vanilla version of
smooth that we try doesn't perform that
well on this dataset but there are a lot
of variants that have been proposed in
literature so the basic idea again it's
a nearest neighborhood based technique
you pick an example from from the
minority class you choose K of its
nearest neighbors case
- Veronica that you can tune and then
randomly choose our of those key
neighbors with replacement so the same
example get can get chosen many times
and now for each of these chosen
neighbors
consider the line joining your original
point and the chosen point and then just
add a synthetic example which lies on
this line so this is a way of adding new
examples which don't over fit the idea
is that if there are any examples that
we missed during our sampling process
then they would like Lowe's - other
examples of the same cloth so here on
the cartoon data set you see this point
gets added between these two this there
is some overlap here that you see there
was no point here that got added and
some of the other points are not very
clear but that's where the new points
are I'll add it so if we run smote with
five nearest neighbors to achieve a
sampling ratio of 0.5 we see a slice
feed
I don't know how clear it is but there
are a lot of examples that get added
between two other examples so the
minority class looks more fluid now and
let's see either performance on the
minority class it does slightly better
than just random over sampling one
percent better than random over sampling
while still maintaining the same
precision on the majority class and as I
alluded to earlier you can combine any
of these two techniques you can combine
any technique here with any other but
there are a lot of combinations that
have been experimented with in
literature that that have had some
success so couple that I review here are
smooth followed by tommix link removal
or smooth followed by edited nearest
neighbors so if we do smooth followed by
Tomica link removal it just I mean
there's no other magic to it other than
just running the two
two techniques in in sequence you see
the data said that you get the the
classifier that unit has is doing much
better and again reflected in the
performance this that's better than
either smooth or automic link remover by
itself to get 80% recall on the minority
class smooth followed by a head routed
nearest neighbors again achieving a
ratio of 0.5 with the size a
neighborhood of 5 tends to do much
better so that mentions mode basically
produces this fluid description of the
minority class by adding synthetic
examples and edited nearest neighbors
then goes and removes the examples from
the majority class that were lying on
top of these and that provides a nicer
delineation between the two classes and
in terms of performance this does really
well on this data set and in fact it's
the best performance that I was able to
get amongst the methods that I've tried
so in terms of precision on the majority
class it's 99% it's better than what we
had gotten off with any of the other
methods and in terms of recall on the
majority on the minority class again
it's 92% much better than any of the
other methods that we had finally I
would like to close with a couple of
ensemble techniques again this use some
variation of resampling but uses more
sophisticated classifiers so easy
ensemble is an unsupervised technique of
creating your classifier so the idea is
to take the sample from randomly under
sample from the majority class to create
a class to create a subset which is of
the same size of the minority class and
then you learn an order boost ensemble
classifier on this data set so let's
call this classifier F sub I you repeat
this for n iterations every time you
resample from the original data set and
you create and classifiers and n is
per kilometer that you can do and then
you're just combining these classifiers
additively so I don't have a
visualization for this because it's a
different classifier that we are using
and to be fair it's not not entirely
fair on the algorithms to compare them
to each other but here basically the
library basically gives you the
different resample versions of the data
set then what I'm doing is doing grid
search and fitting and a doubles
classifier on each of those and finally
on the tests that I am getting the
predictions from each of those
individual classifiers and then just
adding those and essentially averaging
those so the original equation in the
vapor that appears is basically looking
at the sign because the the way they
define the classes is the class labels
are minus 1 to 1 and the the
probabilities here essentially encode
classes as 0 & 1 so that that's the only
difference but essentially it's the same
idea of combining the classifiers
additively performance is fairly good
and you get often get good performance
with these ensemble methods simply
because there are much more powerful
classifiers that are going behind
producing these producing the final meta
classifier the performance on the
precision the precision on the majority
class is 98% all amongst almost the best
that we have and the recall on the
minority class is 90% again almost the
best that we have a different technique
proposed in the same paper is balanced
cascade so we're as easy ensemble
chooses its subset randomly so you
choose the first subset and the second
subset is chosen independently of it but
you can do it in a more supervised
fashion so after choosing the first
subset and building the first ensemble
you remove all examples from your
original majority class that are that
are correctly classified so in some
sense there is some redundancy of
information that is in your majority
class that is what
Kaskade tries to remove and again you
repeat this for n iterations and then
combine them additively so yeah there is
a difference in the way balance cascade
is implemented in the library versus how
its described in the paper because the
the library doesn't return this and the
classifiers that are used at each state
and also allows you to specify your own
classifier it doesn't have to be
adaboost but different classifiers tend
to give similar performance so here what
I have done is implemented my own
version of balanced cascade so on each
subset that their library returns I am
learning an adaboost classifier and then
computing probabilities in the same way
so the code looks similar to easy
ensemble except that the data set is
subsequently changed the performance is
quite good you get 99% precision on the
majority class the best that we have and
the recall in the minority class is 91%
which is again almost the best here
there is slight difference compared to
the previous one where I didn't do a
good search to get the best parameter
just because that that's the way it's
described we that's the way the ballas
cascade samples are implemented in the
library you can do grid search as well
to get the best parameters and there's
not adds this additional line of code or
additional two lines of code the
performance is not very different the
precision on the majority class is the
same that we call on the minority
classes a percent so in closing I would
like to say in the spirit of the no free
lunch theorem that there is there is no
single method that's going to be a
panacea to your balancing goes you
basically have different methods that
you can experiment with on different
methods work well with different data
distributions different classifiers and
different objective so this is one way
of achieving some performance that we
desire it it might not really be what
you want to achieve on your unbalanced
dataset so you'll have to experiment and
see what works best for you
this is not an exhaustive list of
techniques there are a lot of other
techniques that are proposed in
literature given some examples here have
not really explored a lot of these very
deeply but this these are good starting
points all of these come from highly
cited literature on the subject and
there are some references here which you
can look up
then Pilate down the slice would be
available on PI later finally we only
talked about one kind of imbalance here
the between class imbalance so notice
the very first slide where we or the
very first visualization where we chose
the dataset to have two distinct
clusters but you're each of your
individual classes might have several
sub clusters among them and then we have
to deal with how the method performs
with respect to each of these sub
classes so that's that's again a
different area of research and there is
some some techniques of how to handle
that in the reference that I have here
so that's all I have is there any
questions I can take those yes
yeah so the problem with having a metric
so the question is having just a metric
that focuses on the precision on the
minority class the problem with having a
single metric like that which is we just
focuses on one classes that you you can
cheat and basically get achieve that
very easily right you can just table
every example as the minority class and
you have you have two hundred percent
recall there there there are ways of
combining this like I said you can you
can combine the two metrics into a
single one using like something like
area under the curve or something like
harmonic mean of these two metrics
and
yeah I don't have an immediate answer to
that again it's it's really difficult to
make any generalizations you have to
look at the kind of data distribution
that you have and see what kind of
method works for you
question about the free lunch so I was
actually really happy and surprised to
see how well the random under sampling
of the majority did so I want to know in
your experience at Walmart Labs
presumably have lots of high dimensional
data I deal with a lot of high
dimensional data do these things
actually apply to that I mean we did the
saw a nice example of lower dimensional
stuff but what what actually works with
high dimensional data yeah so I've
actually had an experience with highly
unbalanced data distribution essentially
I do a lot of text mining so the number
of features tend to be in tens of
thousands or even millions and I have
worked with datasets where the
distribution is about 10 is to 5 or
something like that random under
sampling actually works really well in a
lot of cases and together with using the
class width parameter if you can do some
cross-validation over the class weights
that that can get you quite far although
in if you have text data in my
experience those techniques tend to be
the ones that I go for it's not just
about the performance but also about
training time if you use something fancy
like smoke for example it takes forever
to train on high dimensional data sets
yeah exactly I mean in yeah in some
sense it's free ish lunch it might not
get you the best performance but it
might get you good enough performance
that is that gels well with your other
objectives is to have classifiers that
train pretty fast and are easier to
understand and easy fast enough to
predict as well
okay
also you mean the problem is that when
we are talking about some kind of under
sampling or weighting of different
classes there is an inherent notion of a
class in the picture what you can do is
take your underlying dataset and look at
the different you can segment a dataset
by different features and then depending
on what kind of features that you have
you might want to upgrade the examples
belonging to or having a particular
feature so that's one way of resampling
the data set again a priori it's hard to
say how well it will do but there is no
natural notion of class there so you
will have to manufacture one
okay thank you thank you